[Musik]
ich freue mich sehr in korneuburg zu
sein und dass wir heute hier auch gehört
sagt truppe das neue die kontamination
system mammut übergeben dürfen
ein top modernes gerät wo wir auch
international den vergleich nicht
scheuen
ich bin sehr sehr froh dass diese
anschaffung über die bühne gegangen ist
da im positiven sinne auch wo das damit
auch ein schutz und hilfe für unsere
bevölkerung dank gewährleistet werden
kann wenn es andere nicht mehr können
wünschen alles gute damit ich freue mich
schon auf den nächsten besuch
das hinter mir sehen sie das dekorations
fahrzeug mammut das ist der satz wir uns
halten es lkw mit diesem fahrzeug können
wir personen fahrzeuge geräte waffen
gelände infrastruktur dekontaminieren
dekontaminieren
das ist das entgiften in strahlend und
den zweifeln von gefahrstoffen
giftstoffen dass keine werden für
personen durchführen hier schaffen wir
40 personen pro stunde
wir können es auch für fahrzeuge
durchführen können sich vorstellen dass
keine militärische fahrzeuge sein
das können auch zivile lkws seien mit
hänger bis hin zu flugzeugen
das schaffen wir haben zwei
großfahrzeuge oder gepanzerte fahrzeuge
pro stunde
wir fangen auch das abwasser auf und das
abwasser wird entsorgt in
dementsprechend entsorgungsfirmen das
heißt wir schauen auch auf die umwelt
das ja nichts in den boden gelangt
zusätzlich können wir mit diesem
fahrzeug sind sieben geräte
dekontaminieren
und wir haben auch einen riesensprung in
der kleingeräte dekontamination da wir
neue technologien verwenden also die
module bestehen aus einem personen die
kombinations modul das die dusche
verbaut mit den zelten damit mehr
personen durch dekontaminieren können
das zweite modul ist für die
dekontamination von sensiblen gerät das
heißt wir können notebooks kameras
sticks bisher einrichtungen
dekontaminieren und kleingeräte
dekontamination sprich waffen helme
handschuhe was auch immer dazu ein
soldat bei sich trägt in der heizungs
und heißdampf kammer und wir haben das
modul 1 das ist das größte modell für
die fahrzeug konfiguration der
gerätekombination